bonjour à tous alors avec philippe juvin
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de la
france de l'europe et des républicains
d'abord l'agenda des jours à venir
aujourd'hui président sarkozy et à
puteaux dans les hauts-de-seine pour
s'entretenir avec les élus du territoire
s'intéressait à nouveau au thème de la
petite enfance et dédicacer la france
pour la vie demain nous tenons ici à
partir de 8h30 rue de vaugirard temps de
travail sur les questions de défense
sujet qu'elle veut qu'elle préside ans
maintenant dans le figaro le président
conclura vers midi cette matinée de
travail sur les questions de défense il
sera jeudi dont le rhône dans la
circonscription de philippe meunier
je vous annonce aussi que le 18 mai nous
aurons un temps de travail sur les
questions européennes
le 25 mai sur la protection sociale
le président parallèlement poursuit ses
déplacements il se rendra sur l'île de
la réunion le 27 mai et le 21 juin il
sera à berlin où il rencontrera
notamment madame merkel
voilà l'agenda donc très nourris sur le
fond sur les déplacements qui permet de
vous démontrer que c'est ici que ça se
passe
c'est ici que se bâtit l'alternance et
c'est ici que se préparent les grands
rendez-vous de 2017
on va maintenant vous parler d'europe on
est neuf mais ce n'est pas robert
schuman qui va s'exprimer mais c'est
philippe juvin c'est encore mieux
tour de l'horloge rue de vaugirard merci
beaucoup goûté sur les affaires
européennes un peu d'actualité tout
d'abord évidemment la journée la journée
dite de l'europe avec la question du
bric site ce qui dans le référendum
approche dans quelques semaines il ya eu
une interview dans le figaro ce matin du
président du mouvement qui a très bien
expliqué en fait la problématique
ou bien les britanniques sorte on en
tire les conséquences
avec tous les effets dévastateurs que ça
sur la grande bretagne et probablement
aussi sur sur nous ou bien les
britanniques restent et s'il reste cela
doit être aussi une occasion pour nous
de faire des propositions de rénovation
de l'europe est typiquement typiquement
nous pensons qu'il faut un nouveau
traité pour redéfinir des contours avec
en fait une europe qui serait une europe
de l'euro très très intégré il manque à
l'europe de l'euro une gouvernance il
manque à l'europe de l'euro une
fiscalité homogène est homogène qui
permet de faire airbags au cou au cou
de boutoir de crise économique
asymétrique il faut des euro-obligations
bref il faut une panoplie d'union
européenne zone euro que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui un fumeur beaucoup plus
intégrer d'autres parties une europe ne
sera pas une robe dans la zone euro et
qui fera un autre choix celui de
l'association intelligente choisit
souvent thématiques
bref c'est cela que nous nous pensons
nécessaire pour que tout simplement
l'europe continue à fonctionner puisque
on voit bien à travers la crise des
migrants
la question posée par le brr excite les
la question grecque qui va revenir sur
la table dans les semaines à venir qu'on
a un vrai problème institutionnel et
donc nous souhaitons ce nouveau traité
deuxième point sur l'actualité
européenne c'est la question des visas
turc alors vous avez pu observer dans
l'actualité que la commission européenne
va faire une proposition à la au
parlement européen et au conseil pour
libéraliser les visas des ressortissants
turcs pour les visas cours de trois mois
et nous sommes non seulement comme vous
savez très opposés à l'accord qui
prévoit cette libéralisation mais
l'accord globalement c'est à dire qu' il
y avait la question migratoire à régler
et nous avons accepté à la demande de
monsieur erdogan de mettre dans le
panier de la discussion des tas de
sujets qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
question du traitement de l'immigration
illégale et en particulier la question
des visas pour les ressortissants
ressortissants turcs
malheureusement la france a été absente
des négociations c'est l'allemagne qui a
fait cavalier seul et aujourd'hui nous
avons une proposition sur la table
proposition législative de règlement par
la commission européenne qui veut
libéraliser les visas turc
nous sommes opposés à cette
libéralisation pour les ressortissants
turcs et nous posons une question
aujourd'hui
la commission européenne publie un
document dans ce document il est
expliqué qu'il y a il y à 72 critères à
remplir pour qu'un pays bénéficient de
l'exemption des visas est donc dans ce
document de la commission européenne qui
date du 4 mai vous avez les 72
critères qui sont passés en revue et
nous apprenons à la lecture de ce
document car sur les 72 critères et bien
il y en a 10
il y en a 67 qui sont remplis 67 72 et
nous sommes très surpris de ce résultat
pourquoi parce que si vous reprenez le
même document qui date d'il ya deux mois
donc c'est pas il ya dix ans il ya deux
mois de la commission européenne qui
étudiait l'existence de ces critères et
est il ou non remplies il y a deux mois
et bien il ya deux mois 19 des critères
étaient remplis donc il y a quelque
chose de miraculeux passé de 19 à 67
critères en deux mois ce que nous
croyons c'est que simplement sur
commande politique la commission
européenne a décidé de considérer qu'un
me remplit les critères qu'ils n'étaient
que partiellement rempli et pourquoi la
commission européenne fait ça elle fait
ça parce qu'il ya une commande politique
des états qui comptent et les états qui
compte en réalité sont un état qui
compte c'est l'allemagne
l'allemagne a demandé à la commission
européenne de faire en sorte que
l'accord soit acceptable nous
considérons qu'il n'est pas acceptable
en l'état
non seulement à cause de cette vision
très très libre de la lecture des
critères qui comme vous l'avez compris
ne sont probablement pas aussi remplie
qui ne le sont que la commission prétend
qu'il le soit les aussi parce que
admettons que 67 critères sur 72 soit
remplie il y en a actuellement 5 qui ne
seraient pas remplies et 5
considérablement important la turquie
n'a pas de législation sur la protection
des données et la turquie ne joue pas le
rôle le jeu d'europol la turquie ne
jouent pas le jeu de l'union européenne
en matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
à la loi qu'il faut enfin la turquie n'a
pas de passeport biométrique et vous
savez que la libéralisation des visas
des possibles que si vous pouvez
présenter un passeport biométrique et
bien non seulement nous pensons que 67
des critères ne sont pas remplies
contrairement à ce que dit la commission
européenne c'est pas possible qu'en deux
mois la turquie ait pu remplir et puis
passer de 19 à 67 et nous pensons en
plus qu'au delà des 67 les critères qui
manquent sur des critères fondamentaux
pour la sécurité des européens et nous
souhaitons qu'il n'y ait pas d'accord
du parlement et du conseil et maintenant
la balle est dans le camp de françois
hollande françois hollande doit
construire une majorité pour qu'à une
minorité de blocage pour faire en sorte
que ce texte ne soit pas acceptée
ce texte sera acceptée de la commission
s'il ya un accord du parlement nous
votre compte
et s'il ya une majorité qualifiée au
conseil 55% des états représentant 65%
de la population à françois hollande de
faire le job est de faire en sorte que
la france ne se retrouve pas seul et
puissent bloquer ce texte deuxième texte
peut-être sur les questions européennes
très rapidement la question du taffetas
là aussi vous avez entendu parler de
position de plus en plus aigu du
gouvernement français en disant nous
allons refuser le taffetas à ça tombe
bien nous nous considérons que sur tout
un tas de critères aujourd'hui le traité
n'est pas bien négocié si les critères
sont bien négociés
nous soutiendrons le traité mais s'ils
ne sont pas nous y opposerons là où nous
trouvons la faire totalement incroyable
c'est que le président de la république
est le président et le premier ministre
se réveille aujourd'hui alors que ça
fait quatre ans que les négociations
durent et qu'on ne les a pas entendu
qu'on les a pas vus à la manoeuvre
auprès de la commission européenne il se
réveille très tardivement pour faire en
fait du traité transatlantique un seul
et unique objet électorale ce qui
évidemment nous déplaît fortement
enfin dernier point peut-être un texte
qui va être votée cette semaine à
strasbourg qui est un texte qui porte un
nom très européen c'est à dire
extrêmement compliqué avec beaucoup de
mots et de lettres pour qu'on comprend
pas quand on lit le titre je vous lis le
titre quand même c'est la directive sur
la coopération administrative et les
échanges d'information de quoi il s'agit
plus prosaïquement il s'agit d'un texte
très important de lutte contre l'
optimisation fiscale des entreprises en
europe
l'idée c'est de contraindre les
multinationales qui font plus de 750
millions d'euros le chiffre d'affaires a
publié des rapports pays par pays pour
qu'on puisse savoir où ils font des
affaires et pour que les pays
successivement puisse connaître la base
d'imposition est ce qu'il pourrait en
tirer en matière d'imposition
le principe est simple les républicains
vol que les multinationales paient des
impôts dans les pays
font des bénéfices ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui et cette directive pour
laquelle nous allons voter et les
républicains à la soutiendrons cette
semaine vise à cela voilà sur les
questions européennes enchères guillaume
tu as la parole de nouveau merci à
philippe juvin de démontrer très
précisément que françois hollande à
bruxelles se comporte en président
somnambule président somnambule
incapable de défendre l'intérêt national
cette affaire turc est très
symptomatique de ce qui aura été le
quinquennat de françois hollande à
bruxelles l'intéret de la france n'est
en rien défendu la libéralisation des
visas pour 80 millions de turcs
ce serait une folie directement
contraire à l'intérêt national et il est
vraiment très triste de voir que la voix
de la france à aucun moment n'a été
exprimée et donc et donc écouter c'est
bruxelles la commission et c'est berlin
qui ont négocié avec ankara à aucun
moment paris n'a été un acteur de cette
négociation le premier ministre
d'ailleurs manuel valls en est à peine
cachée à l'assemblée nationale lorsque
nous l'avons interrogé à deux reprises
c'est assez peu cachée de ce que voilà
la voix de la france comptait pour rien
dans cette affaire et c'est quand même
tout à fait tout à fait scandaleux alors
sur l'actualité de l'assemblée nationale
cette semaine quelques quelques points
nous avons vous le savez cet après midi
nous allons reprendre les débats sur la
loi travail l'alouette conneries on va
donc commencer la discussion de
l'article 1er l'article 1er
techniquement je vous le vous le résume
l'article 1er qui consiste à des
premiers donc c'est censé être un peu le
vaisseau amiral d'un texte le premier
créé une commission de réflexion sur une
réforme du droit du travail commission
qui rendra ses conclusions en 2018
un an après l'élection d'un nouveau
président de la république et d'une
nouvelle assemblée nationale
on est chez les fous cet article 1er
c'est la victoire d'une coalition
hibernatus qui va de jean luc mélenchon
jusqu'à marine le pen en passant par
martine aubry et les frondeurs et
monsieur martinez c'est à dire la
coalition de tous ceux qui ne veulent
rien changer à rien et qui se paie de
mots dès lors pour le gouvernement il ya
plus que des mauvaises solutions
aujourd'hui soit il cède à la gauche de
la gauche
en acceptant de prendre des amendements
qui vont faire de ce texte un texte de
complications du droit du travail soit
ils ne cèdent pas la gauche de sa gauche
et il a recours à l'adoption sans vote
par l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
constitution l'article 49 alinéa 3 ici
nous considérons que c'est un instrument
qui existe dans la constitution et en
tant que tel nous en prenons acte
ce que nous constatons néanmoins c'est
encore une fois le manque total de
cohérence de la part de l'exécutif
je vous cite françois hollande s'exprime
en il ya quelques années
françois hollande premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste disait je le cite le
49-3 est une brutalité un déni de
démocratie
fin de citation si c'est vraiment ce
qu'il pense assez curieux qu'ils
envisagent d'y recourir
tout ce que françois hollande a dit
qu'il ne ferait pas il le fait et tout
ce qui
il a dit qu'il le ferait il ne le fait
pas il continue a promené son
autosatisfaction de cérémonie en
plateaux de télévision il était il ya
quelques jours au théâtre du rond point
même pendant l'uimm et pendant la
commémoration nationale bresson son
propre panier jirik bon nous amener tout
ça n'est pas très intéressant parce que
au fond ce qui est assez triste avec ses
débats sur la loi comme henry c'est que
les vraies questions sont évités tous
les amendements très concret très
opérationnels qui ont été présentées par
les députés républicains et notamment
par isabelle le callennec gérard
cherpion sont écarté d'un revers de main
beaucoup de temps est pris pour un texte
qui ne sera pas au rendez vous des
besoins des entreprises et des salariés
de notre de notre pays
un mot sur emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron un goût certain pour la
géographie des à londres récemment pour
les lever des fonds il est passé par
orléans pour aller non pas entendre des
voix en tout cas l'on cherchait
et voilà on lui dit avec beaucoup de
sympathie que ce serait bien qu'ils
fassent une étape à bercy pour diriger
son son ministère et nous dire ce qu'ils
comptent faire des mois qui viennent
il est quand même le ministre de
l'économie ce n'est pas rien quelle est
sa politique et son action au delà au
delà des mots il faut sans doute qu'il
entre dans le concret qu'il n'oublie pas
de gouvernemnt sur les questions de
sécurité un sujet assez peu évoqués
aujourd'hui dans la dans la presse même
si je me permets de cette remarque
collective qui nécessite d'avoir un peu
plus d'attention c'est le sujet de
l'état d'urgence ça n'est pas banal
d'être en état d'urgence et ça n'est pas
banal comme le fait le gouvernement pour
la troisième fois de venir devant le
parlement avec une loi nous demandant de
projets l'application de l'état
d'urgence il ya une difficulté que je
veux évoquer ici au nom des républicains
qui est une difficulté technique mais
qui aussi une difficulté politique au
sens plein nous avons été un certain
nombre à indiquer que par principe nous
voterions en faveur de la prorogation de
l'état d'urgence
c'est un fait mais le contenu de cet
état d'urgence doit être regardé de très
près l'état d'urgence ça ne doit pas
être une opération de communication
l'état d'urgence c'est un ensemble
d'instruments pour l'action est donc
très concrètement l'état d'urgence ce
sont des pouvoirs de police
administrative renforçait dans les mains
du ministre de l'intérieur et des
préfets le gouvernement vient devant
nous le parlement en nous demandant de
proroger l'application de l'état
d'urgence en justifiant cela par
l'événement majeur que constitue l'euro
2016 c'est un événement qui a une
particularité c'est qu'il se déroule
à date fixe naturellement avec plusieurs
dates qui sont des matches d'un point de
vue opérationnel nous pensons et je veux
le dire avec une certaine solennité
qu'il est absolument nécessaire de se
donner la possibilité de procéder à des
perquisitions administrative avant ces
événements
si les services opérationnels sont
saisie d'éléments d'information qui
nécessite une vérification
le gouvernement a tort de renoncer à la
possibilité d'appliquer ces
perquisitions administrative
c'est un état d'urgence dégradé qui nous
est proposé de prolonger ce n'est pas un
état d'urgence comportant cette
possibilité perquisition administratives
et ça n'est pas un sujet technique c'est
un sujet majeur
je soutiens avec d'autres avec eric
ciotti notamment que bernard cazeneuve
fait une véritable erreur d' analyse ce
qu'il nous dit c'est que le volume des
perquisitions administrative aujourd'hui
est beaucoup plus faible qu il y a
quelques mois entendu mais c'est pas ça
la question
même s'il y avait une seule perquisition
administrative qui permettait d'éviter
un attentat avant un match de l'euro
2016 évidemment ce serait une erreur
tragique une faute que de s'en priver
donc nous appelons le gouvernement à ce
que l'état d'urgence tel qu'il va être
prolongée par la loi comporte bien cette
possibilité de perquisitions
administratives et nous présenterons en
ce sens un amendement que nous
soumettrons au vote de vos votes de
l'assemblée nationale voilà pour l'état
d'urgence vous aurez noté
l'entretien très important consacré ce
matin par le président sarkozy aux
questions de défense
c'est évidemment un sujet absolument
essentiel parce que c'est un sujet
d'intérêt national d'intérêt vital pour
notre pays
nous sommes convaincus qu on assiste
aujourd'hui au fond un retour de
l'histoire
notre génération a probablement vécu
dans l'illusion de la paix perpétuelle
la paix perpétuelle serait une illusion
si on ne se préparait pas assumer
vraiment un effort de défense
le budget de la défense est aujourd'hui
de 30 2 milliards d'euros pour la
première fois depuis 70 ans
l'effort budgétaire consenti par la
france aux questions militaires est
inférieure à l'effort consacré par par
l'allemagne puisque l'allemagne ses 34
milliards ces chiffres étant en euros
constants d'ailleurs et non pas en
parité de pouvoir d'achat j'ai vu que un
journal cette nuit vers 2 heures du
matin a publié sur internet une analyse
chiffrée ce qui prouve d'ailleurs et je
les en remercie tout l'intérêt légitime
que ce journal consacre à l'expression
du du président sarkozy mais nos
chiffres sont évidemment vérifier donc
en euros constants on a bien pour la
première fois et c'est quand même une
rupture historique majeur que de voir
que l'effort budgétaire consacré par la
france aux questions militaires est
désormais inférieur à celui consacré par
par la république fédérale allemande ce
qui montre bien la perte d'influencé de
la france et la nécessité qu'il y aura à
porter cet effort de défense à un niveau
supérieur
je rappelle qu'en 1990 il ya donc 26 ans
le budget militaire français était de 39
milliards d'euros il faudra en réalité
rattrape et rattraper tout cela c'est la
raison pour laquelle le président
sarkozy propose de porter à 85% du pib'
contre 1 5% aujourd'hui cet effort
militaire ce qui voudrait dire 35
milliards d'euros en 2018
41 milliards à l'horizon à l'horizon
2022 pour approcher 2 % du pib en 2025
ce serait un effort national très élevé
mais tout à fait tout à fait essentielle
tout à fait vitale